welcome back now this exclusive in just
a moment former president donald trump
will respond
to president biden's agenda the crisis
at the border
and the attacks on the trump presidency
as the washington post
today is forced to correct quotes of
president trump
that he never made and today department
of homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas
said that the united states is facing
more migrants at the border than it has
in the last
20 years but he stopped short of calling
it a crisis
joining me right now with reaction to
that and a lot more is the 45th
president of the united states
donald j trump mr president thank you so
much for being with me tonight
thank you maria thank you we have we
have so much to get to
with you president biden's first order
of business on january 20th and 21st
was to overturn your policies at the
border
immediately stop construction of the
wall triggering an onslaught of
new illegal immigration your reaction
do you believe this would not have
happened had he not
overturned your policies
well my policies were working better
than they've ever seen on the southern
border the wall is almost complete
we just had to fix little sections
complete little sections that
had to be together we needed them in
order to get the trucks back and forth
from side to side
but they've chosen to stop right in the
middle they could have it finished in
a month and it would be just magnificent
it already is magnificent what it's done
in the areas
where it's totally completed but just
small sections are remaining
and they should finish it but they're
destroying our country people are coming
in by the hundreds of thousands
uh young children are coming in and they
leave their homes and they come up
because they think it's going to be
so wonderful and frankly our country
can't handle it
it is a crisis like uh we've rarely had
and certainly we've never had on the
border but it's going to get much worse
i mean what you're seeing now is very
bad
record numbers but it's going to get
much much worse with a little bit of
time you'll see those numbers expand
at a level like you've never seen before
well you had 400 plus
miles of new wall constructed mr
president of course you
did a deal with mexico to share the
burden
of the illegal immigration the remain of
mexico
policy was something i know that you and
secretary pompeo worked on for a long
time
is there any way to reverse that what
would be your advice for the biden
administration
to stop the bleeding at the border
we'll have great respect for the
president of mexico he's a great
gentleman we had a
very good relationship they had 28
000 soldiers on our border while we were
building the wall
they had 28 000 soldiers not allowing
people to come into our country
and they were also stopping them at
their northern border
by honduras and el salvador guatemala
they were stopping them so they wouldn't
come through mexico and we had it really
down to a good system and as the wall
was finished
they could remove soldiers but they
still had the same 28 000
and we had a great relationship they
understood that
i was playing with tariffs if they
didn't do that but we never had to do
that to mexico because the relationship
that we developed was very very good
very close
and we stopped what was coming into
mexico at their northern border they
stopped that
and they stopped at our southern border
so we had very few people coming in
and we also stopped human trafficking
when i say stopped it
made a tremendous dent like it's never
been made before
and also drug trafficking so we did a
lot of things
and all of that is now eroded today
they're coming in you take a look
they're coming in from all foreign
countries i see they're coming in now
from yemen
they're coming in from the middle east
they're coming in from
everywhere they're dropping them off and
they're they're pouring into our country
it's a disgrace they're going to destroy
our country if they don't do something
about it
yeah we've been talking a lot about this
and the implications there are sexual
assaults
uh mexico's president said that he said
that the cartels view
president biden as the migrant president
look president trump you've had a little
time now to sit back
and think about all of this i want to
get your take on
president biden's agenda including the
border but also this stimulus package
the idea that we are on the doorstep of
much higher taxes
what would be the impact in your view uh
on an economy that
is just beginning to recover
well there were it was recovering under
my administration twice
and we got it to a level that the world
has never seen before
we were the envy of the world and then
when we got hit by the as i call it the
china virus covet
it was it obviously went down along with
every other economy and then we were the
first to get it back up
and we actually the stock market when i
left was
higher slightly higher than it was even
at the prime prior to covet so
it's it was incredible what we were able
to do if you look at the jobs numbers we
had the all-time
highest number of jobs we had 160
million people working we were never
close to that
everything we had african-american
asian-american hispanic-american
everybody was setting records women it
didn't matter
any group was setting records and
now when i look at what's happening we
were energy independent very shortly we
will no longer be energy independent
gas prices are going up at a far more
rapid rate than anybody seen in a long
time
we had gas prices very low and yet we
had more energy jobs that we've ever had
but you know when you see gas prices
going up and they'll be going up by
one dollar two dollars three dollars if
you look at that
and and that's you know that it's bigger
than a tax increase
to the consumer you get a dollar
increase
in gasoline that's a that's bigger
than a tax hike than a big tax hike so
it's a terrible thing that's happening
and then let's talk about tax hikes
they'll be raising taxes at the highest
number that we've ever seen it'll be the
biggest tax increase
in the history of our country to pay for
everything and
it's it's a very devastating thing it's
it's a very sad thing to watch
fortunately in my administration and
through
what i did frankly and others but what i
did with the fda
is i forced them to move quickly and we
got the vaccine done in nine months
instead of five years
i don't think it would have ever been
done frankly because according to their
rules and regulations they would have
never had it
but we got a vaccine done in nine months
and fortunately
that's not only gonna save our country
it's gonna save the world
well i'm glad you brought this up mr
president because we just heard from
president biden last week on thursday
he gave his first prime time speech as
you know and he said that
when the coronavirus first showed up and
that was at the beginning of 2020 when
we did have a three and a half percent
unemployment rate
as you just noted but he said that when
the coronavirus first arrived it was met
with silence
for days and weeks and then months there
was no word of your warp speed
program how are you feeling tonight
about the fact that you're not getting
any credit for any of this by the biden
administration in fact
even when it comes to the border nancy
pelosi this weekend said that
the biden administration inherited the
border issues from
the trump administration
so when you go to when you go to the
covet
issue uh we did a great job we get very
little credit for it i closed the
country far
earlier dr fauci and burks and all of
these people that frankly made nothing
but mistakes
they didn't want to do it they didn't
want to keep closer to china
i closed the border to china i closed
the border to europe
italy and all these countries that were
having tremendous problems long before
they wanted me to do it
and if you look at biden he didn't want
to do it months afterwards and then
ultimately he admitted
that he made a mistake in saying that if
i didn't do that we would have had
hundreds of thousands of more lives gone
but the big thing is what i've and i've
always felt that was the most important
is
the vaccine the key was always going to
be the vaccine and when
biden got the vaccine in december and on
january 20th
he made a statement that he doesn't
think we have vaccines no i don't know
did he make that statement as a
statement or did he not actually know
we had the vaccine what's going on there
but he got his shot he got his first
shot on in december on december 21st i
believe
so with the vaccines and with the job
we've done with covert with getting
i inherited empty an empty cupboard
biden failed very badly with the h1n1
with the
as you know uh the the
he had a chance to do something and they
had a tremendous
tremendous failure h1n1 it was a
disaster
and now he's taking over this what he's
taken over
warp speed we had it our military what
they've done in terms of delivery has
been
incredible incredible and we gave up to
1.3 million shots a day before he even
took over
so not only did we have the vaccine and
one thing we did we took a big bet on
this
we started manufacturing the vaccine
before we really knew it worked we saved
many many months
and millions of lives by doing that
because you wouldn't have the vaccine
right now
if we didn't take that chance we knew
what we were doing we knew
that we felt strongly it was going to
work and we took a risk
and the risk was spending billions of
dollars to develop it
before we knew and before we had the
approval that it was going to work
it works incredibly well 95 maybe even
more than that it works incredibly well
and it's really saving our country and
it's saving frankly the world
so so mr president i know that you
received the vaccine mrs trump also got
the vaccine would you recommend
to our audience that they get the
vaccine then
i would i would recommend it and i would
recommend it to
a lot of people that don't want to get
it and a lot of those people voted for
me frankly but
you know i again we have our freedoms
and we have to
live by that and i agree with that also
but it's a great vaccine it's a safe
vaccine and it's
something that works and we've been
working round the clock and
what i got the fda to do this would have
happened this would have happened in
many many
uh years from now if we didn't if i
didn't get involved and if we did get
involved
yeah tell me more about that i remember
you were talking about
when when you were in office you were
talking about the meeting that you held
with the major pharmaceutical company
heads
and you were garnering all of their
support to work together
to ensure that a vaccine was on the
market as soon as possible
and you said that one issue that you
were trying to do was to alleviate
any bureaucracies within the fda how was
it that you were able
to encourage a vaccine on the market
within nine months that was quite
extraordinary
well i wouldn't say the fda loves me but
i pushed them very very hard harder than
they've ever been pushed
and a number of the people in the fda
admitted that and at the end they were
very happy
but they did not like me in fact they
wanted to announce it sometime after the
election
because they just and i i think most
people knew we pretty much had the
vaccine before the election
but they wanted to announce it along
with the drug companies who are not fans
of mine because
if you look at favored nations and all
of the things i've done to bring down
drug prices
nobody's ever done what i've done but
that cost the drug companies a lot of
money in fact they took
tens of millions of dollars of
commercials so they wanted to announce
the vaccine after
and i understand that but somebody had
to do it you will see drug prices
if biden leaves it alone you will see
drug prices favored nations means
we get the price of the lowest nation
whoever pays the lowest
we get that price right now we're the
highest in the world
we will be the lowest in the world
meaning tied for the lowest in the world
the drug companies were very unhappy
with that they never thought anybody
would do it but i did it
so with the vaccine i pushed the fda at
a level that they've never been pushed
before
and they got it done in nine months
instead of five years now the five years
i think would have never happened
because i don't think they would have
ever gotten it done